there's an art to satisfaction
i'm gonna gather the correct team of 3d
whiz kids that we got for this render
challenge
who is the most satisfying renderer here
in the room
that one was immensely satisfying i'm
not satisfied
at all
everybody's stressed out and we need to
chill everybody out
there's an art to satisfaction we've
known this for thousands of years
how do you satisfy someone we need to
have people watch a video and
go like ah that's all we need we need to
bring a little bit of satisfaction to
the world right now to help hatch over
all that dissatisfaction
why don't we just make a whole video out
of it again it's time
that we go back to that let me give you
guys some new satisfying renders and
guess what this time
i'm stepping in i'm going to make a
runner too i'm going to join why are you
leaving
you're stepping in and i have to make
space because this is such a big
presence
stepping in
there's nothing more pure than making a
satisfying render
forget your scripts forget your sets
forget your actors
forget your compositing tricks all we're
doing is making a satisfying render so
i'm going to gather the crack team of 3d
whizz kids that we got here in the
studio we're gonna lay the ground rules
here for this render challenge
ground rules crown rules rules of the
ground
i want to keep this fair no 30 90s i
only have two 20 80s
all right two 20 80s as well we don't
want these fast boys
zooming past us i want to see you guys
take it up a notch i don't want any joke
rangers i want to see the most
satisfying vendors you guys can come up
with so here's the thing
no rules just satisfying that's the only
rule
people are having bad times out there we
gotta satisfy them all right
who's that hey i've got
six cases of red bull oh that's
satisfying six cases
if i'm not in the next video you know
why so griffin may be satisfied and i'm
jealous of that because i'm not
satisfied yet and you're not satisfied
yet so at the end of this week we're
going to come together
we're going to show each other our
renders trying to satisfy each other as
best we can
ready guys cool break yes
we don't have 30 90s we have to go
faster than you guys
i got to figure this out all right we're
trying to figure out what to do here
the most satisfying renders follow that
basic idea of a magic trick we're
turning one thing
into another through vfx so here's my
pitch
futuristic 3d printing method where we
use like smoke that turns
into like solid objects like particles
that in vapors that go
and they make solid objects and every
once in a while on the assembly line the
printer is going to glitch out
the shape doesn't form correctly and we
see this gross looking thing
and maybe like shatters and throws it
away is that satisfying to be trapped in
a dystopian like space factory with
lasers i'm hoping it is
i don't know how many simulation
challenges it's been at this point but
i've lost everyone
i'm tired of losing so this is kind of
important to me i'm going to put a lot
of effort into this
is this satisfying whoa that's kind of
cool but i wouldn't really call it
satisfying
and the reason why i'm looking at these
satisfying videos right now is because
i'm looking for inspiration
i'm trying to find something that is
satisfying
to listen to first
how can i harness that to make a
satisfying render around
you know i love the idea of that
satisfaction that you get from a perfect
loop or something slicing something
perfectly
but what i love even more is emotional
satisfaction and my idea
was to have this little hedgehog who's
shivering in the rain
and then this farmer comes along sees
the little hedgehog he's like well
hedgehog i'm gonna build you a house and
then the next three frames of the
comic are little satisfying house
building
activities and then you have the
hedgehog enjoying his new home which
it gives you that primal satisfaction
and also that emotional satisfaction
that comes along
with a little hedgehog being housed
finally if i have to stay a little late
that's fine i want to make this
sweet hedgehog render i have an idea we
have this plugin called
x particles for cinema 4d i haven't used
it yet so i wanted to
take some time and learn some x
particles and i looked at some tutorials
and there's one thing that looked really
cool which is
their granular fluid simulation a way to
simulate things like sand
or snow immediately start thinking about
sand castles and how fun
and satisfying it is to smash sand
castles i mean ideally you're not
smashing someone else's sand castles
unless they give you permission
so what if instead of sand sculptures
with snow sculptures i take classic
statues like like the venus the milo
and i make it out of snow and then i
have like swords going
through the whole thing and slice it all
the pieces i feel like cutting things or
splitting things apart and satisfying
renders are a little cliche at this
point they're overplayed
so i don't want to have anything like
that but this got me wondering what if
something like fits into place
so perfectly now we're getting into like
machining tolerances right like i find
that satisfying so i'm wondering if
there's a way i can emulate that
what if i do puzzle pieces everyone
knows puzzle pieces
then i can have multiple going in one
after another
and then just barely lines up perfectly
and ideally
the top surface of it is the same
surface as the surrounding ground
so that you can't tell it was never
there
i have a direction i think this will
work well
okay before the guys get started on
their satisfying renders i've realized
something
how do you determine the success of what
makes something satisfying how do you
determine the parameters by which
somebody could create something to be
satisfying i've got some thoughts i want
to offer them to sam and i think it'll
be beneficial for him
guess who it is hey sam courtesy of
today's sponsor squarespace
you know i'd like to offer you a few of
my thoughts on that okay hopefully
um it'll help you jake i'm all ears uh
it needs to have a beautiful
award-winning template
ah interesting if you go to
squarespace.com templates
you'll be able to see exactly what i'm
talking about head on over there
right now yeah just yeah just head on
over there
such a simple url anyone can type that
now do you see how these templates sort
of give you
an arrangement identity that's going to
be satisfying to the consumer who's
going to be on your website oh yeah when
people actually go on to a squarespace
site
it's already got this inherent sense of
satisfaction which i think is really
cool
you know another thing you might notice
is that nothing is built
entirely by itself you know with
squarespace's multiple contributors tool
you can have multiple team members
contribute to uh your your website or in
this case
you know your render interesting i've
never thought about
multiple people satisfying a render
well now you have is that all no there's
a couple more things i just need you to
know about um
don't forget squarespace has members
areas now i don't know what this has to
do with satisfying renders but if you
have a squarespace website
you can create a members area and have
subscription paying members
partake in the content that's on that
part of your site isn't that great
what if we got into exclusive renders oh
that kind of sounds like nfps
obviously they have great traffic
overviews tools so when you do create
your satisfying renders and you post
them on your satisfying website
you will be satisfied knowing how people
are utilizing your site
you know what's more satisfying than a
render a graph that charts
your users satisfaction with that render
if you want to know even more
head on over to squarespace.com corridor
crew
and you'll get 10 percent off the first
purchase of a website or domain
wow that's satisfying all right well
until
until next time looking forward to uh
satisfying you with this render
and uh i guess you can go to squarespace
to
satisfy whoever the hell you want
i'll talk to you later man good luck
thanks
gonna need it so got all the assets
prepped
time for a day of blasting through
animations i'm thinking i have either
six or seven small tiny little shots i
think it's doable but i'm really happy
with what i have so far
hey what is up andrew kramer here
so here i have a 3d model which is a
scan of adidas to milo
and what i have happening here is it
spawns
a bunch of granular objects basically
all these particles
stick to each other they have a bunch of
parameters and as these swords slice
through it
they stay chunked up so let's try
elevating the number of particles here
oh that's a lot more particles so let's
take it up again
so once i get to this point i need to
really be dialed in i need to be
confident that's working
it take a long time to do so i kind of
set it up and then i had to go and i
give it three or four hours and i come
back to the computer or i run it on a
separate computer or i do it overnight
but once i got my physics style then now
it's not hard for me to do other things
with that
now i can grab a different statue apply
the exact same physics and i can slice
it with swords or in this case
smush it right when you look at the big
scene here this is all just kit matched
parts
vitaly bulgarov kit bash parts he's
great he's just a great designer
so i've got this like environment here
but i need my
actual smoke box or whatever to form
well
i gotta fill up a shape so i make my
shape here you basically just put a
smoke emitter inside that shape
and i actually have the emitter spin
around basically i want to like
i'm like painting the inside of this 3d
object
it has taken the shape of my object i
then
actually bring it into my scene here i'm
creating like a rainbow gradient within
the smoke itself i'm animating the
colors
as it moves so i can have it cycle
through way more than it normally would
and i've specifically put in little
strobe lights so one flash goes off
and then when the second flash goes boom
and now it's
this new object so to take that idea to
the next level that's where we started
to do the the broken pieces
instead of completely filling the
structure i just half fill it
and then i'm actually turning the smoke
simulations into objects
all right my animation is mostly in
place here i haven't figured out my
camera
animation yet but i finally got
everything loopable and tileable
so i hit play this thing comes rolling
in
so now i just need to basically
replicate that motion for the other four
blocks
remember the end blocks are the same
block halfway through each of those
blocks will be the looping point
essentially
but before i go further i really gotta
figure out what the sounds are gonna be
this is what i was talking about these
are those little like green styrofoam
bricks
what i want to do is i want to soak them
in water i'm going to get a high quality
microphone pointed at this stuff
i'm just going to start going to town
chopping them on a wood block but also
the sound of like a plate getting
scooted across the ground downstairs
i need like a chopping knife
this one is sharp you want to know why
because i bought this one in high school
and donated it to corridor
mom and dad remember when i chopped the
banister with this oh god
yeah this was like my favorite sword
growing up
[Music]
[Laughter]
that sucks this is not the right type of
phone
yeah that's awful oh that's so
unsatisfying awful
[Music]
we're onto something with the sliding
oh
[Music]
all right so i think i have enough to go
off for now i'm gonna finish
off the animation render it overnight
and in the morning i will do all the
sound designs
uh that gives me like half a day to
finish this i got a lot of work left to
do
i think i got something here this is the
magic that happens when you give
yourself the chance to be like
creatively nimble
and to get inspired in the middle of the
project it can be really tough with
deadlines
but really excited to show this one off
uh yeah i think it's kind of satisfying
it's a little intense
with all like the robotics arms and
servos and junk like that
it's like do you think being in a very
intense laser factory is a
calming relaxing place it could be maybe
we'll find out all right time to render
render render
in record time i finished my render it's
completely done
i am going to simultaneously satisfy
everyone here at the same time
so loudly that they'll hear it in
south america i am doing my final
audio review here all those custom
elements layered all together
they actually kind of work i have a
feeling people are going to be really
satisfied
the time is finally upon us we've all
been working away
sweating crying bleeding making the most
satisfying renders we can
and you know what we're finally here
ren was a little late i was on time i
don't know you're talking about
people on the website will know we're
talking about because what we're going
to be doing here after we all take a
look at each other's satisfying renders
we're then going to turn it over to all
of the
live viewers on the corridor digital.com
website so all the subscribers there
have a chance to look at the renders and
they're going to judge us they're going
to sit there and they're going to be
like
i feel satisfied or i don't feel
satisfied hopefully that doesn't happen
they're gonna then tell us who was the
most satisfying so it is up to them it
is up to the corridor digital.com
subscribers so tell us
who is the most satisfying renderer here
in the room
i mean i got a satisfying render and i'm
happy to share it with you
i took a lot of time on this render so
enjoy
[Music]
hey
oh my god this is amazing
that was really good i'm getting pretty
good at this now
dude the sound design is so crunchy
how'd you get so crunchy son
maximize stereo spreader exciter
sam you have a knack for storytelling
even in your renders where
you set a precedent you set our
expectations and you betray those
expectations in a way that's really fun
all right i'm going next speech all
right i decided to do a bunch of
learning for mine
and i did a lot of computation um i had
computers crunching sims
left and right for hours at a time and
here's what we got
[Music]
that's like an ant farm dang so this is
the simulation you were talking about
that took like a million years yeah
[Music]
oh it's still going damn
damn okay that was my favorite yet dude
[Applause]
i sampson's better i know but hey
but that one was immensely satisfying
i'm not satisfied at all all right peter
all right guys this one i didn't know if
i could finish it in time
but i'm happy to say that i did
and i'm really excited for you guys to
see it and so yeah
dude yeah dude you finished it
congratulations
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
oh wow it's really cool it's
really cool peter that's great i love
how the board slid into place now like
the paint spread from the paintbrush
i knew that house at the end looks so
photoreal and hyper detailed
oh man
[Laughter]
well okay i mean i thought i was gonna
have more time to work on this
kickstarter filming challenge day to do
it you're like i'm gonna make a movie
the first three shots here are just like
what they're doing
i know
[Music]
[Applause]
so this time around i want to be able to
actually
have something that's satisfying and i
realized one of the core principles of a
satisfying render is the sound design
so i actually set out from the beginning
to be inspired by sound and form a scene
around it and so that's what happened
here
oh
very nice dude
yes
[Applause]
your materials are really nice they're
glowing like translucent subsurface
scattering whatever materials
very nice he's done it he satisfied all
of us
i've never won one of these satisfying
render challenges and
i'm for once actually feeling pretty
good about my chances at the end of the
day it's up to the website subscribers
so
let's see if they uh agree lucky peter
decided to make a whole pixar film and
couldn't quite finish it in the three
days he had
[Music]
write the name of the person that you
think had the most satisfying render and
[Music]
go
i think the quarter digital.com
subscribers have crowned a true winner
here
[Applause]
my first win finally i actually set out
to try to win this one as hard as i
could this time
because i wanted to satisfy all of you
so leave a comment down below
if i satisfied you and if i didn't let
me know what i got to do
to satisfy you i'll eat whatever you
want me to eat that's a great challenge
everyone
submitted some of their best work yet
for a render challenge if you were
satisfied
you don't need a vote we know they're
all great just write satisfied in the
comments just i want to see a wall of
people writing
satisfied